this video is brought to you by
skillshare
hi
welcome to another episode of cold
fusion where i cover anything in science
technology business or history
imagine a future where playable video
games look as good as pixar movies
imagine if they had lighting that's
realistic and creates presence
what about details that are as crisp as
real life
unreal engine 5 a software that allows
people to build games is getting pretty
damn close to making this a reality
it shows us a future where
photorealistic games might exist a lot
sooner than we think
more importantly it also makes the
process of making games much easier
when unreal engine 5 was announced last
year i had an immediate feeling that
this was going to be big i got that
strong sense that the company was seeing
the direction of an industry and
choosing to act before anyone else
earlier this year unreal engine 5 was
made available to developers and in this
episode we'll take a look at why so many
people are finding unreal engine 5 so
fascinating tv
so just quickly to bring everyone up to
speed what is unreal engine 5 exactly in
simple terms it's the latest generation
of a game building software developed by
epic games it first debuted in 1998 and
has since been used in games such as
fortnite gears of war and rocket league
to begin let's just visually take in
what's just become possible with unreal
engine 5.
[Music]
i want you to note how the light looks
and how it makes the scene feel and also
the level of detail in the scenes
[Music]
so why does it look so good
well it's because of two key components
that epic games has come up with
number one is nanite
this allows for ultra high textures in
games without paying a massive
performance cost and number two is lumen
a revolution in realistic real-time
lighting we'll come back to lumen
shortly but let's start with nanite
according to brian carris the creator of
nanite the demo you're seeing on your
screen only needed three gigabytes of
system ram to run and four gigabytes of
video memory
so just take a look at this demo it
feels almost like a pixar or dreamworks
movie
[Music]
the detail and the lighting just seems
to stand out as different to what we're
used to in games
we're going to explore exactly why it
looks different a little later in the
episode
so usually game graphics demos always
look great but when you get down to it
often what's promised is far from
reality
i was skeptical when i saw this demo of
unreal engine 5 last year but now that
it's released and everyday people are
using it for themselves you can see that
this is indeed real
[Music]
here's some further explanations
um it runs great this is on my my pc
obviously i'm an editor right now so
full screen it here
so what i was talking about before with
that sort of detailed shadows
um
they they get very very sharp and
detailed which is great to be able to
show off that sort of intricate geometry
anyways
[Music]
it's
let's
there there was some uh some
misconceptions that we put this like
crack in here to like hide streaming uh
i i have the whole level loaded in
memory right now
it was actually so that we could just
show the camera getting like really
close to this rock
this is an excuse to put the animation
there it wasn't really to hide any sort
of streaming things
the second major improvement is lumen a
global illumination system that
approximates ray tracing but also
without the huge performance cost
looking closer at the lighting aspect
many current games fake the effects of
how light moves in real life this is
often referred to as pre-baking although
the end results can look good sometimes
light baking can take tens of hours for
complex scenes
and if you want to rotate a single light
source you're going to have to wait a
long time to render the entire scene
again
in movies by say pixar the digital light
is modeled in rays so it can reflect
bounce be absorbed and generally behave
closer to reality this gives it a more
realistic appearance
the only issue is that it can take a
computer minutes or even hours to draw a
single frame in a movie scene
in video games however this isn't
feasible for obvious reasons one frame
per minute gameplay wouldn't be all that
fun
in recent years the advent of ray
tracing has brought the possibility of
cinema quality lighting to games but it
still requires specific expensive and
beefy hardware from nvidia to run and
because of this it's limited it's clear
that there needs to be something new for
the average user
the lumen system offers lighting that's
accurate but without the performance
cost
the developers that i've talked to have
been very excited and i am too
and by the way i am in no way sponsored
by epic games or anything like that i
just think the technology is really cool
[Music]
arguably more important than graphics is
the step change in the ease of producing
video games
in the future games will benefit a great
deal when technical limitations greatly
reduce
once this happens game developers can
stop worrying about the tedious parts
and focus more on important aspects like
gameplay and story
so how does unreal engine 5 fix this
problem
the first way of doing this is by
virtually removing the polygon limit
in games everything that you see is made
out of polygons usually triangles
with traditional methods there's a limit
to what you can put into a given scene
because of this game designers have to
think carefully about how they build a
scene and have to sacrifice quality in
some areas the more objects and detail
you put into a scene the laggier it gets
but now this is no longer the case
nanite makes it possible to put billions
or even trillions of triangles or
polygons into a scene and still have
things running at 30 frames per second
everything can be as detailed everywhere
youtuber callum upton explains further
features of unreal engine 5 is nanite
our virtualized micropolygon geometry
system that frees artists to create as
much geometric detail as the eye can see
virtualized geometry supports orders of
magnitude more triangles without
compromising speed
right now for those of you who aren't
game developers this might not mean much
but i'm going to tell you what this
means currently in unreal engine 4 and
other game engines is a limit on how
many polygons you can have in one scene
uh that's not a thing anymore
they've completely changed the way that
the game engine renders things
there's no longer a limit of one to five
million polygons before your game starts
to lag and get a bit
iffy
you don't need to make things in the
distance less detailed anymore which is
the main step that is time consuming in
game development
because you don't just have to make one
rock
you have to make that rock and then a
lower detailed rock and then an even
lower detailed rock and then a picture
of a rock for in the background that's
but it's it's a time consuming process
that is gone
you just make a rock you throw it in
doesn't matter how detailed it is you
don't have to worry about keeping the
detail low
instead of one to five million polygons
per scene you can go one to five million
polygons per pebble on the floor and
that again is not an exaggeration that's
crazy
as a rule of thumb on average computing
hardware the limit is around 5 to 20
million polygons per scene before
performance begins to drop
this ceiling has been completely removed
just to demonstrate that fact take a
look at these
one instance of this dog is around 10
million polygons
reddit user ionized games put a thousand
of these dogs or 10 billion polygons
into a single scene and were still able
to zoom around at 60 frames per second
with no issues
this was never even possible before
here's another example a reddit user
created a fly-through of the death star
with lumen enabled
[Music]
[Music]
just note the amount of detail and also
how the lighting makes the scene feel
more like a movie than a game
so so far nanite only works on static
immovable objects so characters are out
of the question for this high detail
however epic games are working on
getting the limits of nanite lifted
if we take a look at some other
limitations that have been removed in
games there's no longer any pop in the
draw distance is ridiculously far and
you can see everything all the time with
games becoming easier to make
interesting things begin to happen
a youtube user re-ups remade the
simpsons hit and run complete with a
functional first mission built in unreal
engine 5 in a matter of days
also been an overhaul of character
animations removing countless hours of
work from developers
so i'm going to quickly explain this
those lines
is the game calculating how wide an
object is that you have told your
character to jump over
this animation is not pre-configured
so you don't need 10 different
animations for jumping over and objects
of different sizes so like if an object
was this big you wouldn't need the same
animation as an object this big
because you don't need the full jump
it doesn't even matter anymore you just
tell it measure that object jump that
far
like
it's insane
print script determines her rotation how
high up she jumps how far she needs to
move to get to the other side and where
her feet should land
that is the same animation played in
different ways and not having to be
edited and recalibrated by developers
this is a game changer because again
this eradicates pretty much an entire
person's job which sounds great and
terrible at the same time but for the
gaming industry as a whole this is great
how about motion graphics completely
done in unreal engine 5.
you might be starting to see by now that
this software not only has implications
for games but hobby animators as well
as we start to wrap up the episode let's
take a look at some implementations for
cinema entertainment
amazingly the previous version of unreal
engine was used in the production of the
star wars mandalorian series by disney
if we're going to design the whole set
and game engine ahead of time maybe we
could have some in-camera effects
everything in the volume is designed to
both light the actors and to be a
background that we can directly
photograph so you end up with real-time
final pixels in camera
being able to see the actors point at
things and see what they're looking at
was pretty transformative it gave
everybody context with the added benefit
that if you want to move a mountain from
there to there you can do it instantly
you could switch between
the iceland location to the desert
location all within the same day of
shooting
any sequence where you say oh this
world's not quite right let's just move
it a little bit an extraordinary number
of benefits and advantages for shooting
in that environment it's mind-blowing
what that tool is
here are a couple of snippets of some
short films made with unreal engine 5.
look around to see what your friends are
doing so you guys can fall one at a time
i mean this is a sci-fi movie we still
want to keep it a little bit grounded
and make it more believable so does
anybody have any questions for me here
where's ork
uh yeah we didn't have the time to
retarget him he came with a t-pose so
let's get this over with
uh
[Music]
huh
oh
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey
looking at some of those you may be
wondering how the character models were
done
along with unreal engine 5 the epics
game team has also created metahuman a
character tool that according to the
company can quote replace hundreds of
man days and literally within minutes
users can get results that they would
otherwise take months to achieve
youtuber timo helmus tries to create
himself
[Music]
motion capture is also supported with
some interesting results
so in all of this we haven't talked
about the cost so how much is it
well interestingly unreal engine 5 is
free to use and play around with and
that's great news if you're looking to
see what's possible with your creativity
but how would you begin to use it if
you're a complete beginner today's
sponsor skillshare has you covered an
unreal engine course by greg wundra
takes you step by step on how to design
and create a game level work with
materials sounds lighting effects menu
screens and more using unreal engine 4
which operates very similarly to the
current version so it's still very
useful skillshare also has countless
courses on anything from personal
productivity and business management to
music production web development and
photography
the first 1000 cold fusion subscribers
to click the link in the description
will get a one month free trial of
skillshare so be sure to check out the
link below to get started
okay so back to the video
okay so this is all well and good but
there has to be some negatives here
right
unreal engine is less flexible than its
main competitor unity
also the file sizes are very large
the demo that we saw in the beginning
was 25 gigabytes in size but they used
cinema quality assets so that's kind of
to be expected
another negative is that the human
models still need a bunch of work
they're great for a more cartoony style
but not so much for something realistic
so to summarize unreal engine 5 unlocks
a lot of possibilities for developers
the lumen technology is a game changer
and is also useful in architecture
designs and real-time mock-ups
nanite enables the removal of technical
limits so this makes games easier to
create with a lower barrier for entry
and i think that's ultimately a good
thing and even for the film and
animation industry who knows soon we
might start seeing short films that look
pretty good from complete novices out
there it's all exciting stuff
so to sum up my feelings if you can't
tell i'm very excited about this and
can't wait to see what smaller
developers and triple a game developers
alike do with this new technology when
it's fully released in early 2022
alright so that's it from me thanks for
watching my name is dagogo and you've
been watching cold fusion
now i'm going to leave you with some
images of how gaming will look like in
the very near future
really it's just amazing how far we've
come
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
it's me thinking
[Music]